[Music]
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by ryze
kombucha and i will be taking you
on my own little what i eat in a day
vlog
but first let me talk about my sponsor
rise kombucha
so if you haven't hopped on the kombucha
train yet
kombucha is a sparkling cold tea that
has
naturally occurring probiotics from the
fermentation of good bacteria
plus it has antioxidants and organic
acids from the tea
now i love all things bubbly so
i've been obsessed with kombucha since
it gained popularity
a few years back and rise kombucha has
become
my go-to brand so rise is canadian made
and i see it as a really super delicious
lower sugar alternative to like
sweet soda pop or sparkling juice
especially
if you love a good fizz like me i've
tried a lot of different kombuchas
before
and some of them are just really acidic
and vinegary
while some are just sickly sweet
but i find that ryze's flavors are
really well balanced and smooth
i actually use them to make cocktails
sometimes in fact i've got a great
dark and stormy recipe in the mindful
glow cookbook
and i also just like drink them straight
up in the morning
because they have a little naturally
occurring caffeine
my everyday favorite is the classic
ginger but they have
nine other really unique signature
flavors to choose from
including two new flavors peach and
mango
and lime and matcha these are so
so good the peach and mango reminds me
of summer
and the lime and matcha is just such a
fun and
flavorful take on matcha tea so you can
hit up my description for
some more information on rise now before
we get into the vlog i of course want to
remind you that
what i eat in this video is not a
recommendation
on how you should eat or even an
indication of how
i eat every day this is a random day
in a random week and my needs and food
choices will definitely fluctuate
on the regular so take this as really
just entertainment
and maybe a little bit of inspiration
for snacks and meals
maybe but nothing else okay so
to set the stage i guess i didn't film
my first meal of the day because it
occurred at like
2 a.m while i was pumping and pitch
black so yeah doesn't make for the best
food porn but i literally wake up
starving
and very thirsty in the middle of the
night so i like
shovel dry cereal into my mouth before i
fall back asleep
there are literally cheerios all over my
bed and in my bra
but when you are tired and hungry you
just don't care about those things
so after that i actually wake up for the
day
which life update folks i have been
managing
to sleep until like 5 30 sometimes 6 a.m
thanks to making some serious efforts to
you know better prioritize
my mental and physical health and get a
little bit of
better work and life balance so i had to
spend some time doing some
cbti which basically made me force
myself
to stay up really late which then kind
of just pushed everything out
but this has definitely really helped my
relationship and also my mental health
as you know we hopefully start to see
life go back to normal
and i would love to one day be able to
go to dinner with friends
and not have to be home before 8pm
okay so my morning supplements include
ginger vitamin d and b12
the first as a prokinetic for my
digestion which is part of
my protocol for my sibo elimination
which i'm gonna do a whole video on
don't worry
and then of course my vitamin d and b12
i also take in the morning
because they can be mildly stimulating
and my insomnia
is often back and it sucks now also a
big reminder
please do not take these supplements or
any supplements without speaking to a
professional
about your unique needs just gotta say
that
again for the people in the back okay so
then i go downstairs for a quick
pre-breakfast snack while i make
the kids their breakfast i usually have
water of course first thing i do drink a
lot of water
plain water gasp i know or like
i will crack open a can of aqua because
i like that too but for my first little
meal of the day
i'm having some plain full fat greek
yogurt
with some freeze-dried fruit super
simple
not instagrammable but basically a take
on what i was making the kids anyway
because
this mama does not have time to be a
short order cook
all right so bang out the kids breakfast
get that on the plate get that on the
table
and by the way if you're struggling to
feed your baby or toddler
definitely follow my instagram and my
blog i've got
tons of great recipes and ideas there
for you
all right now once they are set i tag it
out with my hubby and
i try to get a quick little workout in
so i've got the peloton app so i
am doing lots of workouts through that
and i also train with
two different trainers a few times a
week on zoom so
that helps me switch things up and keep
things fun and interesting
while of course we are still in this
cove at times without access to
my gym then after a workout i will nurse
oh
i then get them down for a nap and i
pray that poppy does not bark at
somebody outside
and e doesn't like slam one of his
trucks into a wall
because oh is super sensitive to sound
like even with the white noise on full
blast
he will wake up if i so much as like
put a dish into the dishwasher okay so
with baby
down it's time to do some things for me
uh my working hours in this current two
child two entrepreneur setup are
limited so i currently get about three
hours of work done a day
and the timer is already chicken so i
cannot waste any time trying to make an
elaborate
huge to-do breakfast gotta make it
super duper quick so this is a strange
hack
but when i'm feeling like having just
like a straight-up bowl of cereal
but i want to make it more satisfying i
add a little protein powder
to the milk which kind of flavors the
milk
and then also boosts up the protein and
then i will just add in
whatever cereal i feel like so today i
did a mixture of
cheerios and puffins and then i'm just
serving that up
with some peanut butter toast with some
banana
and a little crunchy granola and some
hemp hearts and honey
and some extra fruit on the side tell me
that doesn't look delicious so i know
this sounds
super strange and it kind of was it was
actually like an
accident invention as most my recipes
are
but it's a great hack to make more
kind of simple lower sugar cereals taste
more flavorful give them different
different flavors different
days of the week depending on what kind
of protein powder you use so this is
birthday cake protein powder so now i
have birthday cake
uh cereal and also leave me a comment
below if you also mix your cereals
because i feel like i can't just have
one cereal in a bowl i like to mix it up
now let's be real the only way to make
this better is coffee of course
so i go through phases by lattes but
right now i'm doing
soy milk because i love the flavor and
also the extra protein
and then i will like top it off with
extra almond milk
so it's not too bitter but also if it's
too much soy milk i find it too sweet
i'll have a double short low fat no foam
latte double short low fat no foam latte
nutmeg nutmeg no thanks
it inflames my stomach lining anyways
i'm picky about these things
well that's ironic literally just ran
out of water
just before the espresso went in
ugh it's like a mom's worst nightmare
that could have been a tragedy and just
for that i am going to do
a double shot i wish i could say that i
took my own advice
and like avoid distractions and
electronics while i'm eating and don't
multitask and all that stuff
but honestly there's just so few hours
in the day
especially if you have so few hours that
i get to work in the day
so i am super limited and if i don't
eat while on my computer answering
emails
i risk not eating at all and that's a
problem because i got hangry
i got super cranky and also my breast
milk
supply tanks and i'm feeding another
human so that's my priority right now
so eating while i am answering my emails
is just my current reality at least
until
my eldest gets to preschool please god
willing
uh covet won't be too bad by fall
but yeah i'm gonna get to it
[Music]
cheers okay so i should also mention
that i drink a lot of water
probably like a good three liters as a
mixture of sparkling water
and regular water and lacroix i love it
but i'm a breastfeeding mama
so i am always freaking
thirsty all right one more coffee but
make a decaf
and i know you're thinking like well
what is even the point of that abby
and the point is the ritual
when i get to sit down to a nice hot
latte decaf or otherwise
i just feel more relaxed it calms me
down
i know that coffee's supposed to do the
opposite but it just it means to me
that i'm getting just like a little tiny
moment of silence in my day child free
bliss
and i love my kids like obsessed with
them
but i need like just a little bit of
time to myself
where nobody's grabbing me or touching
me or like
screaming and whining for me yeah
so this i'm just gonna enjoy this
all right moving on to lunch
i was going to go do lunch but then i
got a huge delivery of
all these fun clothes that i ordered
online i don't know about you guys but i
pretty much spent the last year plus not
buying myself
anything so now that people are getting
vaccinated
and i got vaccinated i just had like
this like urge to
go a bit crazy on the online shopping
and buy myself lots of clothes
in the hope that maybe i get to go
outside to the outside world one day and
see other humans
which means maybe i don't want to just
be living in my house coat
i don't know we'll see we'll see how i
feel over the next
few months might be a little bit crazy
going outside my comfort zone
but i got some new clothes so let's try
them on
fashion show fashion show fashion show
at lunch
okay so i surveyed instagram for
high-waisted
shorts because i can't handle the heat
in toronto so long pants not gonna
happen
i got two main suggestions for aritzia
and
um lululemon so these are the lululemons
and they are very comfortable
i got the shortest ones because i don't
know i find when i wear
like long shorts my legs are just so
long they look
weird anyways i love these they're very
comfortable they're the line and i'm
obsessed with
white so let's try ritzy okay so these
are the origias
[Music]
um i think i like the align texture
better they're definitely lighter
these ones have a little bit more
structure to them if that's what you're
looking for but
both i'm happy with these purchases
this is like a terry cloth romper
and at first i was like it's a little
bananas
in pajamas but i'm feeling it now i
don't know
i went for the baby blue because i love
blue on me
and now it feels like a little pajama e
but
it's so comfortable no pockets though
that's a problem
just just want to put my hands in
something
rizzia add some pockets this is the
reformation and i actually just realized
that the romper is also reformation so
sorry ritzia that message was for
reformation
this is pretty minus the nursing bra set
up thing
yeah no pocket still
[Music]
everything needs a pocket just so
everyone knows yes this is
so pretty also reformation and obviously
you would wear this with like
high-waisted jeans or something
um but it's like a little little short
for my torso
but i love this love the color this is a
little
this is a little obnoxious but
that is fixable so yeah love
got a good basic in blue erizia
and i love the v-necks because they're
easy to just
pop a boob out but yeah so comfortable i
have this t-shirt in like every color
another quickie this is a bodysuit
which are annoying but i do like them
right
really really really cool stylish and
obviously it shouldn't be worn with
lululemon's butt or a nursing tank that
is obnoxious
but i'm going to keep it and i like it
and it's it's comfortable so
living for the comfort and also very
easy for
boob access love this oritsia dress
this one's got pockets how cute is this
[Music]
and this color gorge love it nice nice
mint green
she's a keeper also love this one it's
the same fabric it's like stretchy
and comfortable this one's like a wrap
i'm gonna do like a salsa
yeah i love it and it's so comfortable i
could wear like a bathing suit over this
good for cottage life good for just
hanging outside
oh it's so cozy maybe i'll get some more
colors i'm so happy by this
this shopping haul because this never
happens i usually send back
more than what i buy so we got all wins
across the board this is a miracle
okay now i'm hungry let's eat and
lunches are pretty much always a
hodgepodge over here
so then they're leftovers sometimes
they're just like whatever i've meal
prepped in the fridge
in a bowl um but today a little bit more
sensible because i actually went grocery
shopping
uh there are days when i've got
literally nothing in the fridge and i'm
eating
a rogue piece of pita from the freezer
with some cream cheese
and hemp hearts or something but today
i actually had some veggie soup that i
bought from italy
so good i've actually been trying to
limit my raw veggie intake because
just not so nice in my gut and i find
that cooked vegetables and soups
are a gentler way to get that produce in
i also had some leftover chicken that i
had grilled up the night before so
i thought i would make like a little
grilled chicken pita wrap
but it turns out that the pitas i got at
the grocery store
could not be stuffed nor could they be
wrapped
so i ended up with some kind of like
flat pita
sandwich situation but anyways i made it
work
uh slapped on some store-bought hummus
and some prosciutto
added in some chopped cucumbers and
tomatoes and spinach
and i smashed that chicken in there and
i served it with some of the ninja
vegetables
that tried to escape from my sandwich so
yeah i
shovel that in with the kids so that's
why you're not seeing me
because i'm eating with my children one
day i won't have to stress shovel soup
into my mouth
this is not good for my digestion but
after lunch
the kids have their naps and oh
struggles with his afternoon nap
and let's be real if it's a crap nap it
becomes a crap night
and mama just don't have the bandwidth
for that right now so
i spend like an hour walking him around
in a stroller while i'm like
on tick tock and doing other writing
other emails and things like that
which is annoying but also not so bad
when the weather is as beautiful as it
has been
now when i'm done i usually have to pee
desperately
and i am ready for a snack
so as i said at the top of the video i
do love kombucha
always have i think it's just such a
flavorful low sugar alternative to soda
pop
and i love that bright acidic flavor
i think i said in another video once
that my favorite flavor
is acid and yeah i think that's why
i love these kind of tangy flavors so
much
so this is ryze's peach and mango flavor
which
screams summer to me plus it's a
gut-friendly option which you guys know
i need
with everything happening in my belly
right now i also had to put a little
snack
so i had some leftover edamame and some
chopped up mango with tajin
which is the most delicious seasoning
mix ever
it's like spicy salty sweet limey
the only seasoning you need this summer
other than everything but the bagel just
saying
i don't know which is more delicious
it's so hard to say so one is more sweet
one is more for savory wouldn't put
everything but the bagel seasoning on
mango
but definitely would on edamame
so yeah you tell me which one is your
favorite between those two
all right i am going to finish my little
snack here uh
and spend the afternoon with the kiddos
outside because it is gorge outside
bubbles bubble party
now it's mama time so e and i also spent
some time whipping up a little dessert
by making
jello with blueberry juice and gelatin
and then shaping it
like dinosaurs so fun it was just like
an easy activity to do together
and i am always trying to get him
involved in the kitchen
whenever i can i'm gonna pour this in
here
okay you do it okay i'll try some
okay you can stick your finger in to try
sweet
yummy yeah
that looks good i'm trying something
well wait till it's set baby
i do i did
[Music]
well i might not have enough for all
them so we can start with this one
how do you do these ones
i need more for these ones well look
there's only a tiny bit left so i guess
i'm gonna give it to the t-rex because
he is
the greatest one of all
oh god don't tell him don't tell anyone
and speaking of family favorite foods
dinner was pasta night and because it
was like
already 5 p.m i decided to do a really
super easy fast cheater veggie bolognese
yep because you do not need to make
everything from scratch folks
in order for it to be a healthy meal so
i often like to mix
my pasta with some spaghetti squash
whenever i have one
it just adds micronutrients and fiber
and it introduces another
veggie to the kids so i let e help me
scrape out the seeds which
again is a really nice way to get buy-in
for some new veggies or foods if they're
unsure about trying them
now for pasta you guys know i love my
chickpea pasta
it's just a really great way to get more
fiber and protein
and honestly some days e just doesn't
want
any sauce or any kind of protein or meat
and he just wants to eat it really plain
so at least then i know that he's
getting a little bit of protein in
and because i am using chickpea pasta
this is another reason that i like to
mix it with the squash
for myself since i can only tolerate
so much fodmaps from the chickpea pasta
so adding in that squash definitely
helps me feel satisfied
without having bad symptoms as for the
sauce
i actually had bought this really great
marinara sauce from ely which definitely
helped me cut down on cooking time and
then for my protein
i just threw in a can of rinsed lentils
and like a couple handfuls of spinach i
also had meal prepped some zucchini with
italian seasoning earlier
so we had that on board to just like
add the bowl as well
[Music]
also note e's dino jello
turned out pretty good i gotta say and
just an fyi i always serve these plate
up with a cookie
or something sweet or some kind of
dessert and i put it
right on his plate with the rest of his
food so it's not to give
any more power to the dessert than to
his pasta or his vegetable or his meat
or whatever
like this is just another food and if
you want to learn more about raising an
intuitive competent eater
check out my video right here now i'm
going to give my family the privacy to
eat alone
and do bedtime routines so i will meet
you
on the flip side at snack if you want to
make the food
you gotta eat the food so let's go get a
snack
and by that i mean breastfeeding and
pumping as i do
every night before bed makes you hungry
as f so your girl needs a good bedtime
snack
now i love cottage cheese and it is a
really great
pre-bedtime snack because it's rich in
casein protein
which is a slow digesting protein so i
basically like to top mine off with some
berries
almonds and chocolate chips you guys
know that as
the hunger crushing combo
[Music]
a little bit of texture from a chocolate
chip
so good okay so i was just putting my
milk away in the downstairs freezer and
i remembered we've got mini
cheesecakes oh my god look at these
eenie meenie miney moe catch a cheese
pick potato
if he hollers let him go eeny meeny miny
no it is like
frozen solid i mean it's been in the
deep freezer for a couple months
so i need to let it fall out
and i also want to go to bed so i'm
going to probably put it in the fridge
and let it kind of thaw out a little bit
get a little softer
and i'll have this for my snack tomorrow
or breakfast
i don't know we'll see how the morning
goes we'll see how the night goes
yeah mom life hashtag mom life how could
that look oh
super excited maybe i'll take two out
just in case
just in case it's really good all right
let's get ready for bed
okay so now we do the bedtime routine
which you can watch in a lot more detail
right here but a quickie on my
supplements before bed
i take my prenatal sunflower lecithin
l-glutamine for my digestion omega-3
magnesium calm fiber supplement and
melatonin
but again please do not start a
supplement regimen
without speaking to your doctor first
and folks that is all that i eat in a
day
again many more reminders that this is
not a prescription of what you should
eat
this is not an indication of what i
always eat and a big reminder to
listen to your body and speak to a
dietitian and doctor about your unique
healthcare needs
thank you again to ryze for sponsoring
this video if you liked it be sure to
give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on
what other vlog content you want me to
do subscribe to the channel and i will
see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
you